[Music]
[Applause]
Bills Dolphins Sunday night and the AFC
East is at stake Dan Marino former
Dolphins quarterback and Jim Kelly
former Buffalo Bills quarterback both
Hall of Famers joining us on the program
thanks for joining us guys uh when's the
first time you guys
met uh je you want to answer that J
we met uh at Jack Lambert's football
camp and uh we were both just got in
college I think we were young we were
like freshman or something like and uh
and uh it was um like I want to say it
was like in lioner where the Steelers
have their their training camp and uh
yeah that we met that was long time ago
yeah and the thing about that is also is
of course both of us grown up being
Steeler fans and when you're invited to
be a coach at a Jack Lambert football
camp you jump on it yeah and that's
exactly what both of us did we got to
meet each other we've been friends ever
since Dan did you get an offer to join
the usfl I know Jim went to the usfl but
was there any thought of you playing you
know in the usfl wow that's out of
nowhere Dan thank you um yeah I got
drafted by the LA Express now everybody
knows like Steve Young was the one that
signed a contract a year later but I got
drafted I had an opportunity to go to
the LA Express yes I did and uh they um
unlike they they paid Jim a lot of money
down there in Houston they didn't want
to pay
me Jim how close were you not going to
the
usfl what that no I was asking Jim how
close he was to not going to the
usfl well long story short um you have
to remember remember Dan was drafted by
the Dolphins or he could go to the l
express back then I was drafted by the
Buffalo Bills and I was drafted really
by the Chicago Blitz and bottom line is
long story short um we were in the
office ready to sign the contract with
the Buffalo Bills and um Bruce Allen who
was I think the general manager at the
time yeah uh called the Bill's office
and he got the secretary to interrupt
our meeting and he went out my agent
went out and talked to Bruce and uh he
said well they offering you and um my
agent told me he said oh no he said
don't sign that he said we we we'll give
him a a lot better deal he can pick any
team in the usfl he wants and we will
pay him more money that's about all I
need to hear because if you remember Dan
and Dan back then the Buffalo Bills were
not very good I think they went after I
signed with Houston they went back to
back two and 14 season so that wasn't
very good how much competition was there
between all of you guys who were drafted
that
year uh I I mean I can answer that I
think that uh you know just the the
competitiveness of the the great players
there in that first round in that draft
the quarterbacks there was a lot of uh
yes to con just to compete um especially
you know inside the AFC East you know
you're playing the Buffalo Bills you're
playing you know against Jim Kelly and
and those guys and the Jets and it was
Kenny O'Brien and and um it was just
very compet and Tony een yeah was very
competitive and uh it's just part of it
that's what made it great that's what
made it you know so special well I
wonder about this with Elway and Montana
and how much competition there was with
those guys all and I don't know Dan I
know you fairly well as far as being a
great competitor and C certainly you Jim
but do you take it personally like when
somebody says oh that guy's a better
quarterback than you and you're going to
go face that quarterback did you take it
personally like that
Dan um no I felt that uh you know to me
there was a lot of respect involved and
that's the main thing to respect Jim Joe
John all those guys but at the same time
you feel like you're going to go in
there and you're you know whip their
butt like you get that's that's what you
want to do you want to do that every day
that's why you're becoming or you are a
great quarterback or you've been a great
quarterback or whatever the circumstance
may be but that's what it's about and
but to me I always respected those guys
for what they did because I knew what
they went through I knew what I was
going through and I always had respect
for what they did as a professionals and
as also as friends as time went on in
life well what do you guys think about
first balance hall of fame maybe a
different shade of jacket for the hall
of fame or maybe a different level for
where your uh your bust is Jim I'll
start with you well to be honest with
you I grew up in a little small town
east Brady Pennsylvania Dan knows about
this and uh you I personally yeah just
like all boy little boys growing up in
Pittsburgh or Buffalo or whatever you
have your dreams your dream is to play
professional football well my town was
so small that nobody ever thought about
yeah you can dream just like every kid
does but um when I finally made it there
and you you dream about the NFL and
being able to take care of Mom and Dad
for me making my five brothers proud of
me that was awesome never in a million
years thinking Hall of Fame then as time
goes on you play well and you do well
the Talk starts coming out and there's
nothing you can do about it but uh um it
was to go back back from the previous
question Dan the the respect that you
have and all the guys that you've grown
up with you you played the game with is
play a game against I should say h the
respect Factor has always been here
especially between Dan and I because we
knew each other a lot longer before we
were you know good players in college
football and then of course the NFL and
then now with the builds against the
dolphin year in the year I I don't mean
to change the subject a little bit but
to Dan to to ARA this one it's not like
it used to be I mean when we were best
friends off the field but when we got on
the field we yeah enemies to a certain
point but it I just don't get the
feeling of builds against the Dolphins
now like it used to be back in our day
did you guys you know shake hands and
hug after the
game always always okay that's my guy
right there that you're talk Jim Kelly
is my man I love him forever forever and
and uh even when I was playing uh you
know if it wasn't like mean look Jim
Kelly for the Buffalo Bills was the most
amazing thing that happened to them at
the time because we used to we used to
beat them up pretty good and then they
got Bruce Smith they got cornos P they
got Daryl tally uh and then Jim Kelly
and and they took over and they they
were a great great football team and and
prevented us actually from going to
Super Bowl a couple times because I felt
were good enough to go but we couldn't
we couldn't beat those guys yeah between
that's funny you say it because it's
it's interesting because people always
come up to me a lot of people say you
know what I used to not like you I go
what you're a Dolphin fan you go how did
you know because I met I met so many
people and I'm not going to name names
from the Dolphins organization that said
why did you do that to us I you ruined
my check that I was going to get for
playoffs I you were playing yeah the
front office gets money too I'm like oh
sorry about that we're talking to Dan
Marino and Jim Kelly it's the bills and
the Dolphins coming up Sunday night all
right Kelly just tried to avoid the sack
there with the question Dan let me ask
you what about a different shade what
about a different shade of jacket if
you're first ballot Hall of Famer Dion's
talked about everybody's getting in too
many people getting in your thoughts so
uh personally I I I trust in what the
Hall of Fame is doing uh I think if you
get a gold jacket you deserve to wear a
gold jacket no matter what anybody else
thinks or what they whatever that is uh
you know it's it's it's it's a top of
the the chain as far as football is
concerned and everything that goes with
it to me there should not be any
distinction between a gold jacket okay
that's fine 10 years now or if you get
in the first Ballot or if you get every
Vote or I mean it does me it doesn't
matter it's it's awesome to to get in
and to be a part of that group I am like
I said about respect for Jim respect for
nothing but the greatest for all the
Hall of Famers not doubt where are your
jackets right
now mine's uh in Florida okay my buffalo
in my closet hanging up we got a couple
damn we got a couple jackets uh Patrick
we got a couple jackets now because I
know least I grew out of mine and then I
grew into it and then I grew out of it
again so they got a coup as a matter of
fact last year they re fitted us for New
jackets so we're going to be going on to
the third jacket but to make a long
story short what Dan was saying I agree
100% gold jacket is a gold jacket and I
don't know many people that ever dreamt
about being in the Hall of Fame more so
playing in the NFL but to get into the
Hall of Fame when you walk into the room
at least when I did you see guys like
Joe namoth and Terry br R Bob greasy all
the guys you looked up to and admiring
and idolizing um you see them in the
room then you see Deon Jones and guys
like that you're like wow I'm a part of
this now it's uh there's nothing like it
ever and uh I'm just thankful to God
that uh I was able to do it and be a
part of guys and be friends like with
Dan which I consider one of the greatest
players ever played the game on and off
the field Dan Marino Hall of Famer and
uh had a Super Bowl appearance with the
dolphins five-time passing leader
nine-time pro bowler you know that Pro
Bowl doesn't sound as impressive as it
used to be where guys are getting in and
might be the fifth alternate um how many
pro bowl you're a five-time pro bowler
Jim so
uh why why do we it feels like there
should be that designation of those who
got into the Pro Bowl this year
yesterday those are your pro bowlers not
the fifth quarterback who is going to be
an alternate here where do you guys is
also when we were getting in they were
only picking two quarterbacks early in
our careers okay so I mean it was hard
to get into the Pro Bowl because a lot
of guys played in them like Dan I don't
think Dan played in hardly any did you
play in any no I played in three out of
the N nine Time pro board he played in
three you always had a little injury Dan
you always had an injury I had
postseason stuff to deal with you know
then also there was
a more more importantly all right Dan
I'm gonna have you assess Jim's
quarterback for his team and then Jim
you do the same for Dan's team so you
Dan look at Josh Allen and what do you
see uh well Josh Allen is
uh know he's an amazing player because
of what he brings to the table every day
and every week and he don't miss games
and he he uh he can run he's physical
and he also can throw the ball you know
as well as anybody in the league and uh
and you could tell that you know he
loves to compete uh he's tough and uh
he's you know for for the Dolphins in
that you know having to deal with him a
lot is is it's tough It's hard and uh
we're gonna have our work cut out for us
the Dolphins uh this week because of guy
like Josh Allen and how he plays Jim
said Tu a Tong of
Viola first of all I think I could
pronounce it Tu a Tong of Viola
correct I think Dan messed that up wait
I screwed that up I think you did but
that's okay wait it's not to a tongue of
aloa yeah yeah that's what that's what
Jim just said I now you now you
corrected why why are you starting with
it why no this is what Marino does come
on don't double team me like this that's
not right that's not yeah well I think
got I got the twoa correct there I got
the Tua correct there all right Jim one
out of two ain't bad Dan you're doing
good but uh no I think uh his accuracy
is
unbelievable um I think he's done a good
job of getting the ball to the guys and
letting them do the work and that's why
I try to always I know my old cliche you
take what they give you because too many
times I see people trying to go deep all
the time not just Josh but other people
and I I get it to a certain point but
Tom Brady lived on that little short
Crossing route and give it to the
receivers let them run with it and two
has got two of the top receivers uh in
hill and of course WD and I'm not sure
if wd's playing or not or how healthy he
is uh but uh yeah he's he's got all the
ammunition around him to play well and
that's what you need I mean you had
duper and Clayton I had Lofton and James
uh James Lofton and Andre Reed on my
side so we had great guys just like two
has now and I know the bill have digs
but I'll tell you what it's going to be
a battle and I can't I can't wait to
watch it Jim when the Super Bowl was in
Minneapolis did you guys go to Prince's
house who's Prince the singer no I
didn't I don't know to be to be honest
with you I don't I don't remember I I
remember something you brought up about
that a long time ago but no I never did
okay you went out other places you just
didn't go to princess oh we have to you
know we have to have dinner and stuff
like that yeah we went to other places
uh but once uh you know Friday rolled
around we were focused on what we had to
do most of us I can't say
everything line is we got jacked a lot
by people saying are you guys party too
much you had too much fun you know why
we won when you win you have fun and and
Dan know just when you're a little
um superstitious you things like that
happen so it's uh one of those things
you just wait wait wait a minute you're
saying you had to celebrate you had to
party because that that was you have to
party Jim you had to
party when you're superstitious you do
what you did the week before week before
that if you're winning you do the same
thing if you're losing you try to change
up what you did before we tried that we
went from our first Super Bowl to our
second Super Bowl and then two three and
four every year we said well maybe if we
do this and we change it up a little bit
we might win one unfortunately it never
worked Dan did you have that same logic
that whatever you did the previous week
I kind of yeah you know what I'm a
little more boring than Jim was was was
talking about that I I uh I kind of did
the same routine no matter what so but I
would change up a little bit but I
wasn't that superstitious that you know
had to worry about how I got dressed and
all the other things it was more a
certain routine that I was in but uh you
know those guys were such great players
and all that they could handle going out
and partying and also playing well
believe
me Jim's the Tom Brady of
beverages
I I used to be okay I I don't do that
I'm I mean I'm I'm going through some
other things going on and I can't really
have a I'm in dread chapella it's Dan's
high school teammate I'm down in Miami
now and we drank a bottle of wine last
night and I go bro this is not tasting
as good we usually does so but a long
story short times change oh my God you'd
walk into a bar he's got a lot of money
drink all his expensive wine please the
uh oh we already did we broke a bunch of
his uh C and all his uh bring some bring
some to the game Sunday night have bring
the game you know I can't bring that
into the stadium I I think I can get you
arranged I think you probably could too
Jim just give the wine to Marino he can
bring it in
without a doubt yeah yeah but I have to
make sure that there's I bring three
balls I'll end up with one before he
gets
there great to talk to you guys uh Happy
the Friendship continues and uh thanks
for joining us have fun on Sunday night
Dan thank
you love you guys all right Dan Marino
Jim
Kelly you know been friends for a long
long
time you'd walk into a bar you didn't
want to see the Kelly Brothers if Jim
was Jim there and you saw his brothers
it's like oh boy